this was a powerful show of patriotism
in moscow russia's biggest stadium was
filled to its 81 000 capacity to
celebrate eight years since the
annexation of crimea or as it's called
here the reunification
and everywhere the zed the sign that
first appeared on russian military
vehicles in ukraine and has now become a
symbol of support for russia's war there
it was a stage set for vladimir putin
who told the crowd that the united
states is using ukraine to threaten
russia he's had the soldiers fighting
their illustrated russian unity
shoulder to shoulder they help each
other support each other and when needed
they shield each other from bullets with
their bodies like brothers
such unity we have not had for a long
time
a survey after the first week of the war
showed that what the kremlin calls its
special operation in ukraine was
supported by 58 percent of russians
there have been attempts to protest
against the war but they are quickly
often brutally suppressed
but others are finding ways to voice
their opposition such as this art group
called party of the dead protesting
somewhere in russia
we are practically living on a war
footing there's no way for it not to
affect us anymore we have to fight this
war and those who are stoking it keeping
it going and are prepared to take it to
some catastrophic finale that show of
descent won't get covered by russian
television
but friday's flag waving in moscow and
other cities will though you won't hear
that ukraine says it's fighting for its
survival or that the west dismisses
accusations that it wants to rip russia
apart bernard smith al jazeera moscow